we can talk now
to somebody who i think can tell us a
little bit more about what it is uh like
uh to be a target of uh russia and
whether the uh sanctions are gonna work
bill bralda has campaigned around the
world for sanctions on the putin regime
he's the author of freezing order and he
joins us now i just give a bit of
background to
i guess your own history with
russia
i was the largest foreign investor in
russia from 1995 to 2005 and i um
exposed corruption and the companies i
invested in
in retaliation i was expelled from the
country declared a threat to national
security
my offices in moscow were raided i had a
young lawyer named sergey magnitsky
investigate the reason for the office
raid he discovered that
the purpose was for these
corrupt police officers and other
officials to steal
230 million dollars of taxes that we
paid to the russian government
he exposed it testified against the
officials and he was subsequently
arrested
tortured for 358 days and murdered
in russian police custody
on november 16 2009
since then i've been on a mission to get
justice for sergey
and which is culminated in something
called the magnitsky act the magnitsky
act freezes the assets and bans the
visas
of the people who did that and people
who commit similar human rights abuses
in russia and around the world the
magnitsky act now exists in 34 countries
and is the template which is being used
to sanction oligarchs and putin cronies
in this war on ukraine
and so from one individual murder we now
have one of the most prolific tools to
deal with this terrible atrocity which
is going on every day in ukraine
okay i'm interested to know on your view
on the sanctions that the west have
imposed on
russia do you think they're effective
and if they're not what more could be
done
well the way i view sanctions is kind of
like medicine for disease it depends on
at which stage of the disease you've
taken the medicine
so had we started to sanction just a few
oligarchs let's say five before
um russia or putin i should say invaded
ukraine um he would have seen that we
had the capacity to do this he i think
his calculation was that we were never
going to do this type of sanctioning
because over the last 22 years he's done
a lot of other terrible things terrible
atrocities and we've always looked the
other way he invaded georgia nothing
crimea taking crimea nothing salisbury
nothing
um and many many other things nothing
and so he he was sort of under the
impression that this this was uh
uh gonna be the same thing with ukraine
had we just done a bit of the
sanctioning he might have changed his
calculus now that he's
invaded putin doesn't have a reverse
gear he doesn't have any capacity to
compromise to back down to show weakness
and so the purpose of the sanctions at
this point is not to change his mind
i don't think the sanctions will change
the oligarchs minds either because they
don't have any effect on on putin they
can't
they're they're subordinate to him
the effect the purpose of sanctions at
this point in my opinion is that we want
to starve putin
uh of all the financial resources
that he has to wage this war if we can
cut off his money in every different way
including by sanctioning the oligarchs
and sanctioning the russian government
etc um then perhaps in the future he's
not going to have the money to do what
he's he's been doing and plans to do
when we spoke to oliver dowden a little
bit earlier in the program he's a member
of the government here in the united
kingdom he said that he would like to
see germany and france doing more
is there a question that when some
european countries are still pumping
billions of pounds into russia in return
for oil and gas that actually the
sanctions are going to only have a
limited impact
well he's pointed out the elephant in
the room so we've done uh more
sanctioning of russia than
than anyone has done of any country in
history um freezing the central bank
reserves um freezing the oligarchs
cutting off russian banks from swift but
he's right and as you say every day
um uh europe germany france italy
austria various other places who are
totally dependent on russian gas
send vladimir putin a billion dollars
every day
and so just to put in really simple
terms
um this war costs vladimir putin a
billion dollars a day and every day he
gets a billion dollars from europe and
so that's kind of a wash
and so if we really do want to um stop
this war and we want to stop it from
spreading which is i think the biggest
concern we should all have
then we have to stop giving them the
money and to stop giving them the money
that means that um germany is going to
have to tighten their belt significantly
they're going to have to experience some
economic pain
and and they can say well this is
disproportionate you know what about the
uk which only gets three percent of
their gas
well i would argue that germany has put
themselves in this position they very
stridently argued um with the rest of
the world to become more dependent on
russian gas they built a pipeline to
become more dependent on russian gas and
a pipeline that was supposed to bypass
and effectively squeeze ukraine
economically and so i think that germany
has a big duty here i completely agree
that that um uh germany is sort of
sitting sitting in a very um
hypocritical seat right now
they're they're closer to the front line
than we are and and they're continuing
to to give putin money to pay for
weapons to kill ukrainians and
potentially kill other people in europe